Today we're going to talk about the real
reason why you wake up at 3:00 a.m. in
the middle of the night. This problem
getting up in the middle of the night is
not an adrenal problem. And I taught
people in many videos, if you have a
problem in the middle of the night, it's
an adrenal problem. Well, I am changing
my viewpoint on that. I recently
stumbled on some information that is
just mind-blowing, and I'm going to
share it with you. And this is going to
solve a lot of problems for you.
Especially if you wake up between 1 and
3 and you're just totally wide awake.
Your heart's pounding and you look at
the clock and you're like, "Oh no, it's
between 2 or 3 a.m. Why am I waking up?"
I remember when I had this problem, I
took so many adrenal supplements and I
did not get better. In fact, it took me
a very long time before I actually was
able to sleep through the night. My main
point is when you solve the wrong
problem, you will not be able to get rid
of your issue. And this is the big
problem with medicine as well. They're
not treating the root cause or treating
this symptom. So, this is a video to
clarify something, get you on the right
track, and what I'm going to share with
you is actually going to blow you away,
but it's going to help you sleep, too.
If you're a little bit skeptical, that's
totally fine. Just hear me out. When you
go to sleep at night, your brain is near
100% dependent on the fuel from the
liver, not the muscles. It cannot tap
into the fuel from the muscle. That's
like the stored sugar in the muscle.
It's called glycogen. It can't use any
of that. Typically, a healthy liver
should have enough stored sugar to be
able to feed the brain through the whole
night without any problem. But if you
have a fatty liver, okay, the way that
you know you have a fatty liver is if
you have a belly. If you look down, you
can see your belly. That means you have
a fatty liver. But that's not the only
way. Some people have skinny fat and
they basically have a lot of liver fat,
but you can't really tell. But one
obvious way is if you have a gut. If
your liver is inflamed, you're going to
have a problem storing fuel for the
brain. If you have scar tissue in the
liver, that's called cerosis, you're
going to have a problem. But the most
common reason why the liver cannot feed
the brain at night is because of
something called insulin resistance. And
all I want you to think about when I
talk about insulin resistance is that
you no longer have any way to stop the
blood sugar that is made by the liver.
So at night your liver can actually make
sugar and that's called
gluconneogenesis.
Gluco meaning glucose neoenesis.
the creation of. So, the problem when
the liver doesn't work right is it makes
excess amounts of sugar. I know you're
saying, "Wait a second, you just
contradicted yourself. If your liver is
making too much sugar, then the brain
should have enough fuel, right?" Yes.
But if there's a liver problem, you are
going to have at least three to maybe
five or more blood sugar swings
throughout the night. In other words,
you'll have a spike of blood sugar and
it'll come down. And what's going to
cause it to come down is insulin. And
here's the thing you really need to
know. When blood sugar comes down on the
low side right here, because it's
constantly being regulated, your brain
is going to say, "Liver, I need fuel."
And that communication is through this
hormone called adrenaline. Adrenaline
mobilizes stored sugar really fast. So,
it'll just bring that sugar right up.
But the problem is at the same time,
adrenaline is a stress hormone, and it's
going to wake you up. You're going to
feel more awake at 3:00 a.m. than you
are during the day. And the hormone that
wakes you up is not even cortisol. It's
this one right here. Cortisol works a
little slower. It's a stress hormone,
but it's more like a wave. And we'll
talk about that, but that's going to
affect you more in the later part of the
night. When you really finally identify
the right problem, you can get it fixed
and things will turn around. And I'm
going to show you very soon what to eat
to fix it. In this blood sugar swing,
the first swing is usually at midnight,
between midnight and 1:00 a.m. And most
people don't notice this swing because
it's very, very minor. But this swing of
blood sugar is occurring and reacting
from your last meal. And you might be
able to get five hours of sleep, maybe
six, but not seven or eight. Now, that
problem is related to cortisol. The
cortisol spike is highest at 8:00 a.m.,
but you might have the spike at 5:00
a.m. waking you up earlier. You want to
fix that problem by readjusting the
circadian light and darkness cycles. So,
in the morning, it's very, very
important to get outside and be exposed
to blue light from the sun. The blue
light actually increases cortisol. So
what's going to happen is you're going
to increase cortisol at the right time
versus staying inside and not being
exposed to that sun, you're not going to
be able to trigger the cortisol and so
everything is pushed forward and you
might experience cortisol later in the
day. But if we start training the body
very consistently to get outside, let
the sun wake us up. Then when it starts
to get dark outside and you start to go
inside your house about 3 hours before
you go to sleep, you want to start
turning down the light. You want to
start dimming things. You don't want
this light, especially blue light from
your LED lights to start to stimulate
more cortisol because blue light, even
from the sun or LED, actually increases
cortisol, but darkness stimulates
melatonin, which actually starts to make
you more tired. The other thing that
happens as we get older is we lose our
sleep pressure. There's an active thing
that pushes us into sleep. It's like a
pressure that pushes us into this
wonderful restful sleep. There are
certain things that you can do if you're
losing that sleep pressure. And I'm just
going to give you a couple tips right
now. Number one, weight training,
exercise, resistance training,
highintensity interval training, doing
physical work outside, all increase that
sleep pressure at night versus not
working out. You're sitting at your desk
in front of the computer all day. You
didn't get a chance to go for a long
walk. You're not going to have any sleep
pressure. Also, avoiding too many
stimulants. So, you want to avoid
drinking too much coffee with caffeine.
Have a little bit, but don't overdo it.
Another thing to increase sleep pressure
is taking magnesium glycinate in the
evening. Lately, I found if I take zinc
with magnesium both together, that
actually helps my sleep even more. So,
you have to realize that the liver has
an external clock that's outside your
brain that it does a lot of the work at
night. And if the liver is
dysfunctional, it's going to interrupt
your sleep. Now, primarily we're
focusing on fuel to the brain, but your
liver does a lot of other things at
night. It actually helps you burn fat.
In fact, the majority of fat burning
occurs at night if the liver is working
right. It detoxifies you. It makes
sugar. I've already talked about that.
It also makes bile to help you digest
fats. And it also clears out histamines.
If the liver is not clearing out
histamines, you're going to wake up with
the stuff he knows. The liver also
breaks down chemicals and toxins and
drugs at night. So the liver is really
really important in the timing of doing
all these things at night. And this is
why it's so important to take care of
your liver because without these
functions, you're going to wake up
feeling really tired. You're not going
to sleep. You're not going to feel
really good. So then the next question
is what causes liver problems, right?
Well, let me just run down the list.
seed oils, high omega-6 inflammatory
oils, especially if they're heated over
and over again in junk foods. So, seed
oils are one component of ultrarocessed
foods. The other two ingredients in
ultrarocessed foods are the sugar and
the starch like malttodextrin, modified
food starch, modified cornstarch. These
are industrial sugars, industrial
starches, deadly on the liver. They're
just going to make the liver really fat.
Also, foods with low choline. Number
five, low sulfur foods. You apparently
need sulfur to be able to detoxify the
liver. Your liver is not a store of
toxins. It's an organ that is supposed
to get rid of toxins and it needs sulfur
foods to get rid of them. I'm going to
explain what foods those are in a
minute. Number six, late night snacking.
I used to snack between the time I would
get done eating dinner till right before
I would go to bed. It was a constant
grazing. I did this for a long period of
time. And that was probably the start of
my downward cycle with my health. Okay.
And of course, you have the alcohol. I
did that for six months. I actually was
drinking these margaritas every night
after work. I got in a habit of it. And
at first it was great. And then after 6
months it was bad because my health
started going down down down. I started
having all sorts of liver problems. One
thing about the liver when you go to bed
at night and you feel like a full
sensation underneath your rib cage and
maybe you get bloating and maybe you
have referred pain to the right shoulder
blade. the liver or the gallbladder or
the little bile ducts are kind of
swollen and there could be stagnant
sludge that is not flowing through from
the liver down into the gallbladder and
then it's creating tension on nerves
specifically the frenic nerve that
shoots pain up here and I've had tension
up on my right shoulder right here for
years I had no idea where that was
coming from sometimes it'd go back into
my right romboid which is the muscle
back here. And I would go to the
chiropractor and get adjusted, adjusted,
adjusted, adjusted. Never fixed it. It
kept coming back because it was related
to my gallbladder and my liver. But my
liver was swoll up and I had that
sensation for such a long time. If you
have that sensation, I'm going to show
you what to do adding foods and
eliminating certain foods. But also, you
want to be sleeping on your right side.
you're going to feel more comfortable or
you're going to sleep better on your
right side because if you sleep on the
left side, the liver is a little too
swollen. It's going to kind of compress
the heart and it could affect your
breathing. But I know with people with
that problem, they're very restless.
They don't sleep very well. I mean, it's
pretty bizarre now that in the past, I'm
talking for like 20 years, I did not
know what that was, but it was like a
constant dull feeling underneath my
right rib cage. Now, I don't even have
any of it, but I used to live with
constant bloating, and I thought that
was kind of a normal thing, but it's
not. I want to mention one more thing.
When people go on the ketogenic diet,
sometimes they have a problem sleeping
through the night, not because keto's
bad, but because of this. Remember I
told you that the brain depends on the
liver for the glucose through the night?
Well, there's another fuel that the
brain can run on, and that's called
ketones.
That's right, ketones. It doesn't have
to run on glucose. In fact, only a small
percentage of the brain really needs
glucose. The great majority of the brain
can run on ketones. And the real cool
thing about this is the small amount of
glucose that the brain needs can be
produced by the liver itself. So, if you
go on the ketogenic diet, which is low
carb, here's the problem. It's going to
take a few days or even sometimes a week
or two to transition into full ketosis.
In the process of doing that, you might
still have problems getting up. For
those people that have problems sleeping
when they start keto, I think the best
recommendation is to slowly kind of do
it, not to do what most people do is
they just dive in and they go really low
carb right off the bat. So, for those
people that have sleeping problems when
they start keto, they should probably go
into
ketosis a little bit slower than usual
and just start cutting down the carbs a
little bit at a time until you get them
below like, you know, 50 and then 30.
And that way, you'll sleep through the
night. But realize it's only going to
take maybe one to two weeks before
you're fully adapted. But the very cool
thing about this is that you don't have
to run the brain on glucose from the
liver. You can run the brain on ketones
from the liver, which by the way is way
better than glucose because they bypass
this insulin resistance problem. You
literally bypass the whole thing and you
get fuel right into the brain and the
results are incredible. So, if you
haven't tried the ketogenic diet, you
need to try it because it's the best way
to not just feed the brain, but actually
to fix this problem right here. But
sometimes, you know, again, like it
takes a couple weeks to transition into
it. All right, here's the plan. Number
one, stop eating 4 hours before bed.
Snacking is the killer. That'll mess you
up. And this is why when you go to the
grocery store, do not buy any junk
foods. Keep your house clear of all
these junk foods, okay? It'll make it a
lot easier because when you go to the
grocery store, you only need to say no
once. But if they're sitting in your
cupboard, you have to keep saying no
every single night. And I know with
myself, even though I have a lot of
discipline, if it's there, it tempts me.
And why not make it easy on yourself?
Number two, you want to start getting
more choline in the diet. How do you do
that? Egg yolks. I don't recommend
consuming just the egg whites. Eat the
whole egg. Egg yolks have choline and
that's going to give you great support
for your liver. Also, if you eat liver,
you'll get choline. Grass-fed meat, you
get choline. Salmon will give you
choline. And even cruciferous vegetables
will give you choline as well. Number
three, we want sulfur foods so we can
detoxify the liver. The more we can
support the detoxification process, the
more you're going to wake up and feel
refreshed and good. So, let's talk about
what foods are high in sulfur. garlic,
onions,
cruciferous, and cabbage is a
cruciferous vegetable. Sauerkraut. I
consume a lot of sauerkraut. But these
foods will give you the sulfur to be
able to support the liver. Now, number
four, you want to support the
gallbladder. The gallbladder is going to
store the bile, make it concentrated.
So, every time you eat, it's going to
contract and push that bile into the
small intestine to start to break down
the fat. not 100% just breaks it down
enough so then the pancreas can come in
with its enzyme lipase to do the rest
and then break it down to the smallest
particles so that it could be absorbed
in the small intestine. So they both
work together. But so many people don't
have enough bile. And so what happens is
their ratio of cholesterol to bile. It's
like too high of cholesterol and not
enough bile. And now it becomes sludge.
And that's what I had. And it kind of
sits in those little ducts and it puts
pressure on the liver and then that's
how you get gallstones. So, one thing to
solve that is to consume foods that are
bitter like arugula, dandelion greens.
Certain bitter herbs all help to
increase the production of bile. There's
one really good remedy that I've
recommended in a lot of videos. It's
called tutka, a type of bile salt. You
would just take two of these on an empty
stomach in the morning and then I
recommend taking two in the afternoon.
Okay? Empty stomach. And what you're
going to notice, it's going to start to
thin the bile. It'll start opening up
these ducts. So, you can get your ducks
in a row, but you're going to actually
feel like, "Wow, I don't feel that
heaviness underneath my right rib cage
anymore. I feel better down here." It
won't back up all this pressure, and
it's really going to help right shoulder
pain. I wish I would have known about
this 20 years ago or 30 years ago. Okay.
Number five, go low carb. Get your body
running on ketones, not glucose through
the night, okay? It's going to solve
your sleep problems. I will promise you
that, okay? But do a high quality
ketogenic diet. Number six, work on your
blood sugar through the low carb because
we want to handle insulin resistance
with these additional things right here.
Apple cider vinegar, like a tablespoon
in a glass of water before meals, can
really help you. And even in the
evenings, greatly help you. Vitamin B1
is one of the best things for mental
stress and you're like thinking before
you go to sleep. It gets rid of mental
tension. It's great for anxiety. But the
main thing it'll do, it'll help with
your mitochondria,
especially if you have diabetes or blood
sugar problems or have a history of
eating a lot of carbs. Magnesium is
super important in sleep, relaxation of
muscles, and lowering of cortisol, and
helping you fix insulin resistance, as
well as this other mineral called
potassium. You can get potassium through
certain foods like avocados or a
potassium electrolyte to help reduce
this insulin resistance. Let's not
forget quality of protein. Animal
protein is needed to actually help you
detox, but it's also needed to help
establish your blood sugars. So listen,
if your liver is healthy, your brain is
going to sleep deeply because the liver
will keep the brain fed all night